hitting the jackpot tells the story of
the Pequot Indians and how they created
Foxwoods Connecticut's first casino this
talk is one hour
good evening I'm Linda Hill the events
coordinator 'drj Julia's and I'd like to
welcome you to tonight's event
Bret Frampton was a staff writer at the
Washington Post and Fortune magazine as
well as chief markets writer for the
street comm he's here tonight to talk
about his new book hitting the jackpot a
fascinating work of investigative
journalism that takes readers into the
lucrative world of India Indian casino
gambling
Frandsen traces the Wheeling's and
dealings of skip Hayward Haywood and
reveals the true inside story of how the
Mashantucket Pequots of Connecticut
turned their Foxwoods casino into a 1.2
billion dollar a year operation making
them the richest Indian tribe in history
please welcome mr. Bret Ronson thanks
Linda evening thanks for coming I
thought I'd just start out first by
briefly explaining how I came to the
story then I thought I would read from
the first chapter and then I would talk
a little bit about the story that
unfolds after that chapter in 1998 I was
down in Washington for the Washington
Post staff writer and I have I'm from
Connecticut and born and raised in
Weston and family all of this day I
heard a lot about the Pequots and
Foxwoods so I went to my editors and I
said well that's got to be a great story
and I've been covering Wall Street in
business for almost 20 years at
Washington Post and fortune and so at
that point they said well why don't you
go up there and see what you can find
out so I did and I spent about a week or
two and I came back and I wrote a story
big story for the paper and needless to
say just scratch the surface and that
was the point at which I thought well
you know this is a this is a heck of a
story and my agent who had been trying
to get me to do a book for a long time
and as anyone who's been a staff writer
knows you never have time to do books
convince me that this was the time and I
did I went into the story initially
thinking that the story of the Pequots
was a great American story of people
bootstrapping themselves to riches and
fame and power through really remarkable
sort of will and grit and what I found
was that that was really only sort of
part of the story and that the story was
similarly American but much more complex
what I wanted to do and what I focused
on doing in the subsequent three years
in Connecticut and elsewhere where I did
my reporting was to really talk to the
Pequots themselves to examine closely
their previously confidential documents
and to examine previously confidential
state of Connecticut documents I felt
that if I was going to do this properly
I really had to get inside that's what I
did and that is the basis of the of the
book that I will talk about and read
from tonight
so what I'd like to start with is the
beginning always a good place to begin
this is from chapter one the title of
this chapter is defeat and decay the
first Puritans migrated from
Massachusetts Bay Colony to Connecticut
colony in 1635 and within two years or
at war with the pequod Indians the
dominant tribe in the region the
Pequod's waged a guerrilla war against
the Puritan settlements and the English
retaliated with punitive strikes on
Pequot villages the main casualties were
civilians elderly men women and children
in the spring of 1637 the Pequod's rated
Wethersfield one of the three English
settlements along the Connecticut River
the others being Hartford in Windsor one
of the three English settlements that
was attacked three women and six men
were killed and two young girls were
kidnapped will the colony's leaders met
in Hartford and decided to launch a
counter-offensive having already lost
more than 30 dead out of a total
population of two
50 faced with the superior Pequod
population about 3,000 according to
modern estimates and surrounded by other
Indian tribes of uncertainties the
English chose as their military
commander a professional soldier named
Captain John Mason though not a Puritan
by any means Mason was a veteran of the
religious wars of the early 17th century
between Catholic Spain and the
Protestants of northern Europe tall
powerfully built and a proven leader in
the field mason was given a hastily
cobbled militia of 90 men they were
joined by 70 Indian warriors under the
command of Uncas chief of the nearby
Mohegan Tribe which was already in
conflict with the Pequots Mason's motley
expedition I forced boarded three small
ships on Wednesday May 20 16:37 for a
trip down the Connecticut River to the
military garrison at Saybrook where the
river met Long Island Sound on the way
the Mohegans disembark preferring to
walk rather than travel and ships that
constantly ran aground in the rivers low
water the Mohegan skirmished along the
way with Pequot war parties but arrived
intact as a fighting force at Saybrook
Mason was impressed with the Mohegans
fighting spirit however other members of
the English expedition doubted their
mettle to test the Mohegans loyalty
mason ordered them to track and capture
dead or alive a small war party of
Pequod seen nearby the Mohegans killed
four Pequod's and brought a fifth
warrior back alive they lashed the
captured warrior who dared them to do
their worst to a post tied a rope to one
of his legs and pulled him apart and
Englishmen finally put a bullet through
the Pequots head to end the torture
Mason was under orders to strike the
main Pequot fortified village but all
rout he decided against a frontal
assault noting that the Pequot fort was
likely to be unlearned and well defended
instead he chose to withdraw from the
area sail east to what is today Rhode
Island and then march back West
surprised in the peak watch from the
rear mason was initially opposed by
those soldiers in his force who felt a
direct attack on the main Pequot fort
was the quickest way to achieve victory
it was only after Minister accompanying
the expedition
announced that he had received word from
God endorsing Mason's proposal that the
captain was able to proceed with his
plan
Mason sent home those who still doubted
his leadership and replaced them with
professional soldiers from the garrison
at Saybrook on Friday May 29 his small
force sailed east toward Rhode Island
which as planned led the Pequots to
assume that Mason was giving up instead
Mason ships landed in Narragansett
territory recruited several hundred of
that tribes warriors and quick march
back into Pequod territory the weather
was exceptionally warm that may in the
English soldiers with their heavy metal
armor leather boots and matchlock guns
labored in the extreme heat from his
Mohegan and Narragansett Scouts Mason
learned that the two largest Pequod
camps were too far apart for him to
attack simultaneously with his small
force he decided to concentrate the
attack on the near of the to a hilltop
fort overlooking the Mystic River the
English rose before daybreak on Friday
June 5th praying together for God to God
for victory they climbed quietly up the
hill to the fort where Mason divided
them into two forces sending one to the
south entrance of the fort while he led
a second force to the north Mason and
his soldiers advanced within 20 feet of
the Pequots wooden palisade before an
Indian dog caught their sense and barked
a Pequot warrior cried out ilanics
ilanics
Englishman Englishman Mason his soldiers
rushed into the fort pushing through a
thorny brush pile intended to block the
entrance once inside the oval-shaped
fortification they form ranks and let go
of olive musket fire down the main Lane
frightened Pequots remained in their
homes
Mason forced his way into one of the
dwellings and killed several Pequot
warriors with his sword a fierce battle
ensued many Pequots were killed but
Mason's force was out manned fearful of
losing a protracted fight
Mason shouted to his men we must burn
them he seized the firebrand entered a
house constructed of tree bark draped
over wooden saplings and set the
dwelling of fire within minutes the
entire fort was engulfed in a hellish
inferno
the screams of Pequot women and children
mingled with the roar of English muskets
and the triumphant shouts of the
Mohegans and their ganses some Pequod's
perished in the flames without
attempting to escape others rushed
directly into the flames either
deliberately or in panic many warriors
fought amid the conflagration until the
bow strings cracked and were rendered
useless still other Pequod fighters
gathered outside the fort and shot their
arrows until cut down by musket volleys
about 40 of the boldest rushed out and
attempted to force their way through the
English lines only a few escaped most
were struck down by the English swords
or Mohegan and Narragansett arrows
tomahawks and war clubs in little more
than an hour close to 400 Pequot men
women and children were killed seven
were taken prisoner and seven escaped
only two Englishmen died in 20 were
wounded following the victory at mystic
the English hunted down the remnants of
the tribe and handed over any survivors
to the Mohegans and their gansan's as
spoils of war a small number of Pequots
were also sold into slavery in the
Caribbean or indentured as servants to
English families in Connecticut
then in 1666 the Pequots under the
control of the Mohegan Tribe were given
a 2,000 acre reservation in what is
today ledyard connecticut those overseen
by the Narragansett were given a
reservation in nearby North Stonington
the days of the Pequots as a major force
in southern New England appeared to have
ended forever we're still in the first
chapter I'm now moving to 1928 what
happened in the interim period was that
those people who were put onto the
reservation in 1666 through migration
assimilation and simply the grinding
down of any kind of American Indian
tribes in southern New England were
really ground down to a nub based on my
reporting the Pequots
really ceased to function as any kind of
a tribe certainly at the latest the late
19th century
I read now here a short section about
what was an observation made about them
by Frank spec by 1928 anthropologist
Frank G SPECT the most dedicated student
in the early 20th century of New England
tribes observed quote the remaining
Pequot in connecticut had become
hopelessly d culture ated unquote one
respects research assistants gladys
tantaquidgeon a college-educated Mohegan
from nearby Montville connecticut wrote
a paper on new england Indians for the
US Interior Department's Bureau of
Indian Affairs the BIA and concurred
with specs assessment she wrote with the
exception of the tribes in Maine the
remaining Indian population in New
England is made up of D culture ated
remnant groups in southern New England
our indian communities have been and
still are melting pots beginning with
the early french and english contacts
and continuing through the later period
of intensive whaling industries along
the coast during which time the men from
many lands married and settled in the
indian communities the match had gone
out and the indian blood continues to
become diluted the infusion of Negro
blood was strong in this portion of the
area in certain tribes and scientists
are of the opinion that many of the
smaller tribes along the coast have
become completely absorbed here there
are but few who are of one-half Indian
blood and a mere handful who can claim
three quarters Indian blood the majority
has one quarter Indian blood or less
what happened in that period of time
from the 30s up through the 40s the 50s
into the 1960s to the Pequod's was it
the tribe
there was no tribe you had basically a
few people living on the reservation you
had one or two dwellings and ultimately
it had ended up that was really just one
elderly lady
Eliza George Plouffe living there
her half-sister would occasionally come
and go
sometimes in Florida sometimes on the
reservation but Eliza really lived alone
she was essentially a ward of the state
of Connecticut she lived through
whatever she could earn by being a
domestic to families in the area and she
received whatever welfare payments were
at that time handed out by the state
Eliza was very very eager not to share
the land with others than her family no
one really wanted to live there frankly
there were no jobs it was a absolute it
was that part of town that no one wanted
to go I'll read a section here about
Eliza's last days by the late 1960s
Eliza's family had shown little interest
in returning to live on the reservation
she expected to die alone and that
afterward the reservation would be
turned into a state park Eliza was
terribly disappointed in her family
especially in her grandchildren who were
coming of age Eliza was determined to
establish in her grandchildren some kind
of interest in their Indian ancestry in
1971 when one of her granddaughters
Teresa darkness Heyward decided to get
married Eliza argued that the young
woman should have quote an Indian
wedding there has not been one here in
three hundred years
unquote ceremony was held on the
reservation atop a flat rock outcropping
where the original Pequod's were said by
local historians to have held their
tribal councils Teresa wearing a
miniskirt with leather fringes that was
was given away by her big brother skip
who wore a store-bought western-style
feather headdress afterward they served
succotash in Turkey and the children
played cowboys and Indians because they
were already dressed for the parts
Robert Hayward Skip's younger brother
later recalled so it was authentic
Pequod even though you know it was done
in the fashion of guesswork there were
probably a lot of different cultures
like middle or western Native American
because a lot of the heritage and
culture was wiped out through the
history even my grandmother didn't
practice it
unquote despite such efforts to foster a
sense of Indian identity
Eliza's grandchildren remained
uninterested skip Heyward a
broad-shouldered six-foot two inch tall
young man particularly disappointed
Eliza of all her grandchildren she felt
that he had the greatest potential to
organize the family and hold on to the
reservation after she died it was not
clear to anyone else that skip was a
natural-born leader armed only with a
high school degree skip was just one of
thousands of unskilled New England kids
scraping by in a slow growth economy his
father wanted him to go into the Navy as
he had but instead skip or skipper as he
was known within the family never got
around to it he floated from job to
unskilled job until he made a deal to
take over a clam shack near the Mystic
Seaport the sea-mist Haven served fried
seafood and hamburgers to locals and
tourists skip took out a small loan from
a local credit union flipped burgers and
clam fritters seven days a week and work
nights as a pipe fitter at a nearby
defense contractor electric boat where
they built nuclear-powered submarines
for the US Navy skip hoped to show his
father that he could make something of
himself Haywood senior was a task master
who would use corporal punishment
liberally on skip and his siblings when
they were younger
as a teenager skip appeared one day at a
cousin's house he looked terrible his
feet were horribly blistered it turned
out that he had walked more than 20
miles to his cousin's house after having
been beaten by his father
the last thing Hayward's senior wanted
however was for skip to get involved
with old Eliza and her derelict
reservation so in early 1973 when Eliza
visited skip at his clam shack to ask
him to take more of an interest in the
reservation he declined she told him
that the state was forming some kind of
Indian council in Hartford and she
wanted skip to represent the family he
told her between this restaurant and
everything else I'm doing nanny
there's just no way I can do it I'm just
too busy after she left skip didn't
think too much more about it in the
spring of 1973 Eliza had a formal
photographic
portrait taken of herself she had been
feeling weaker and weaker and wanted a
photo before she died as a visual legacy
for her children and grandchildren to
remind them of their Pequot ancestry she
called a local photographer whose motto
was a touch of elegance
like most Americans he had a
stereotypical image of American Indians
[ __ ] high cheekbones thick straight
hair the Indians Connecticut had always
disappointed him looking either too
white or too black
it Eliza he saw potential he gave her a
false hairpiece too long thick braids
and a plaid workman's jacket akin to the
Pendleton blanket jackets worn by
western Indian tribes he posed Eliza on
the banks of a local pond in front of a
tree covered hill and an arching sky
Eliza never looked more Indian on June
8th 1973 it was a fine late spring day
Eliza died alone as she had anticipated
in her old house the peach cherry apple
and pear trees were in blossom her
vegetable garden was beginning to fill
up with green beans and peas and summer
squash in the rhubarb patch a small
forest of reddish stalks poked above the
ground out front hollyhocks roses
daffodils and lilies were in various
stages of bloom inside
Eliza's body rested in her old rocker
her heart had simply given out now
that's the end of the first chapter and
you would think well that must be the
end of the story after all with her the
reservation was empty and the only
people left were her immediate family
that's just the beginning of the story
of the Pequod's I mean that is the
amazing thing about this story was that
it that is the point at which 1973 her
children and their children basically go
to the state at that point and this is
of course Connecticut cozy Connecticut
and no one really cares very much about
this 200 acres scrap of land stuck in
the middle of what was then nowhere in
southeastern Connecticut and they go to
the state
this Indian Affairs Council and the
executive director is a young man named
Brendan Kelleher a really nice young man
he's just graduated from the master's
program in anthropology at UConn
University of Connecticut he's a dropout
from the ph.d program and he is the man
who has been appointed by the state of
Connecticut he's being paid $12,000 a
year to represent the state in dealing
with these reservations see the state of
Connecticut didn't think of these
reservations from in tribal terms they
thought of them as pieces of land that
they had with remnant populations going
through the welfare records and the
other records here in the state is very
clear that that is how Connecticut
viewed them well named event this young
man Kelleher who I tracked down he's
actually now up and he's a city manager
up in Vermont these days and I think
happy to be in Vermont and he shows up
and his first introduction to the
Hayward's which is the descendent family
of eliza is basically when he gets a
call from this Theresa darkness Hayward
she's then married someone to it's now
known as teri Belle who says that she's
moving on to the reservation and whether
he likes it or not and she's just
informing him of this and you can
imagine coming straight out of you know
the academia and he's having to deal
with this in your face situation so he
goes down to talk to her and she
basically screams at him and slams the
door in his face and so he says well
maybe I'll go talk to her brother skip
so he finds skip and they agree to have
breakfast at a place when he gets off
the night shift at electric boat and he
says god he says you know maybe can help
me out here because I want to help you
guys but you know there's a problem you
guys are a family this reservation is
supposed to be for a tribe not a family
so you've got to be more tribal so he
was there to help them you have to
understand there's an enormous amount of
white guilt I mean I just read to you
the opening section the contact of the
Pequod's these people were slaughtered
this is a this is the ultimate this is
the first Indian war in New England the
Pequot War
and there's a sense of white guilt
informing Kinetics its whole stance at
this point so keller is a little
concerned because they don't appear to
be a tribe but he's really not there to
do anything other than help them so he
does so what then happened soon is that
he introduces them to some lawyers from
Maine now these guys are big-time this
is Tom tureen associates at pine tree
legal they are the cutting edge at that
point of advancing Indian interests in
the Northeast they at that time we're
representing the Penobscot and past
Makati in landmark land claim striation
against the state of maine and
landowners in order to reclaim tribal
lands that were allegedly transferred
illegally and they're winning in court
they at this point are focused on Maine
but there's this little tiny group down
in Connecticut they send a lawyer down
they do some research to see what the
records are and the records indicate
there was a land transfer from this
reservation in the mid 19th century and
they're pretty excited by this because
what this means is that they might have
a claim to recover land and I won't the
book goes into all the all the gory
details as to how this all happens but
the the nub of it is that Tareen hooks
up with skip Heyward and he holds out to
him something a whole lot better than
access to a state reservation he holds
out the promise of he can get them some
thousands of acres federal recognition
and federal money for some jobs you know
some housing some you know this is a
time still it's post Great Society
there still is money flowing into
Connecticut at that time from Washington
at that time skip is um you know begins
to dream along with Tom now terrine is
under no the confusion about what he's
looking at what he's dealing with
he told me in the course of the
interviews that it was very clear to him
he never ever wanted the question of
tribal authenticity to ever come up
either to the BIA or in any court of law
he had actually run into a very
difficult situation in Massachusetts
some years earlier
with the Mashpee he'd actually taken
Mashpee had had filed a big land claim
suit the land owners had fought back it
had gone to trial and my god
a jury had decided you know what Mashpee
they're not a tribe that was a
devastating loss a terrible loss he
didn't want to risk that here in
Connecticut he was in a really wonderful
sort of wonderful in the sense of from
his point of view he was able to go to
the state of Connecticut which was
basically clueless and say listen
there's this problem here down here with
this we're suing these land owners you
have a little tiny problem here I know
how we can take care of this we'll all
go to Washington we'll go to Capitol
Hill with a piece of legislation I'll
write the legislation and in this bill
essentially what will happen is the
state of Connecticut will transfer
ownership of the land to the federal
government which will then take you know
being a position of trust for the
reservation well that means we have to
give the Pequots
federal status as an Indian tribe which
of course they've never had so we'll do
that and the federal government will
then pay the money to buy the land from
these landowners so everyone comes out
whole and everyone gets what they want
and this is a good thing well this is
essentially what happened and you know
the Connecticut guys in Hartford and our
congressional delegation really led the
way and I mean you know whatever people
think about Foxwoods and the Pequots
today you know significantly you have
your elected officials to thank and I'm
not certain whether the people of
Connecticut have fully appreciated that
but that is true so in an event they get
federal recognition they get this
reservation they expand it by a certain
amount and most importantly what Tom
Tareen had done which the state never
picked up on was in the legislation that
was the settlement legislation
ultimately passed in 1983 and signed had
been vetoed by President Reagan but then
it came back to him with a slight
amendment the state of Connecticut
kicked in a little bit more money and he
then he signed it it passed but in that
bill Connecticut lost regulatory
authority over this reservation
well now Tarina done that you know quite
intentionally he had he'd gone down this
road before with the Penobscot in the
past McQuarrie in 1980 and Maine up in
Maine they'd been a little more shrewd
and they hadn't sort of signed off on
handing over regulatory authority and
that had actually prevented the
Penobscot from getting high stakes bingo
which they had had previously in the
state of managed shut him down and then
the state of Maine had shut him down
pretty permanently in the in their
settlement legislation in 1980 that
basically gave the state control
to that extent over this reservation
when Connecticut no.1 the people were
just not that sophisticated
so after 83 within a you know a couple
of months you know Terenas talking to
skip and they're talking about
high-stakes bingo
they sort of announced this to the state
and the state goes ballistic when this
is announced and they say you do this
we'll shut you down and basically you
know Tareen just has to sort of go
through explaining to them what the law
is and you know disappointingly he's
right of course from the Connecticut
point of view and by 1986 they've got a
high stakes bingo parlor here in the
woods and you know according to the
confidential documents that I got I mean
these are the financial documents
showing exactly how much they were
making and they were making fifteen they
were grossing 15 million a year and they
were showing profits depend upon the
year anywhere between three and five
million a year now this is a group of
people at that time who might have been
50 people maybe that's a considerable
business at that time of course at that
time you know Connecticut is still sort
of thinking well that's sort of annoying
but it's not a big deal well what then
happens is Tareen and other associates
of his remain advance the ball further
and by 1988 you have the Indian Gaming
Regulatory Act which is an attempt by
the states to prevent the spread of
gaming across the United States this was
the intention of that act Tareen and
associates don't see that act as in any
way limiting them in Connecticut and yet
again
they basically go to the state and they
say within a few years they say you know
we like a casino you know a casino you
can just I mean I grew up in Connecticut
I mean my god I remember we had blue
laws this is a state where the liquor
store when I was a child was called a
package store you know and so in any
event they go nuts and they attempt to
stop is people in Connecticut
some people may remember they attempt to
stop this in the Statehouse then
governor weicker is the one who
initially jumps in of course a weicker
had helped advance the Pequod's cause
along with Chris Dodd and Sam gage inson
and then governor O'Neil and governor
Grasso before that I mean this is a
who's who of Connecticut politics who
advanced all this and at this point why
Kerr is now governor it's 1991 and he
says oh my god you know this is crazy he
just can't believe it of course why Kerr
is is is quite a volatile personality as
people in Washington know and people in
Connecticut know and he tries to go to
the state legislature to stop this
terrine is exploiting a state regulatory
exemption for for what's called Las
Vegas nights essentially raising money
for the local church and fire department
low stakes one or two nights something
like that well you know the lawyers from
Maine and the Pequod's say to the state
well you know what you guys have you
have gotta see these are casinos and
we're going to have a casino to we're
just going to regulate it differently
we're going to have it open all the time
and it's gonna be just like Las Vegas
well in any event this is you know why
Kerr goes to the state legislature he
gets completely out lobbied and really
out just beat by the lobbyists for the
Pequots
and it's it's truly quite a yarn and and
and he just he you know the state
legislature he wins in the Senate and
loses in the house and he needed both
houses to support him to get rid of this
Las Vegas night exemption and so there
he is he's stuck with this casino casino
gets built and lo and behold
the next year this they come back the
lawyers from the Pequots come back and
they announce to the to the governor
quietly he said oh by the way we want
slots because they didn't have slots
they only had table games well anyone
who knows anything about the business of
gambling knows that the slots is where
the big money is it's a great business
people come and they give you dollar
bills every day of the year
and you give them 85 cents and change
that's a great business you know I mean
and it's even better than say other
great businesses like liquor and you
know and cigarettes because it doesn't
quite have at least so far it doesn't
have quite the aroma politically that
those industries necessarily do yet at
least not at the federal level well you
know Wiker at that time is thinking oh
my god what am I going to do Steve Wynn
you know the impresario from Atlantic
City and now Vegas he's beating on the
doors the state legislature he's
spreading money everywhere you know he's
everyone's best friend and you know if
the Pequots are going to have Foxwoods
located
you know midway between New York and
Boston will then by golly you know the
non-indian guys want a piece of the
action
so weicker's is sort of between a rock
and a hard place at this point and he
then cuts a secret deal and how he cuts
it cut it is just is pure pure Lowell I
think and and very funny and and and I
think a an example of just what a mess
Connecticut had gotten itself into that
this was really what he thought was the
best decision he could make I won't go
into the details but he cuts the secret
deal and he announces to the state lo
and behold guess what we're giving him
slots but don't worry we're going to get
25% of the slot win and they're
guaranteeing us a hundred million in the
first year
remember this is 1992 not this is a
period 1992-93 this is a period of time
of recession and fiscal crisis in New
England and especially in Connecticut of
course the current moment this is the
same thing as going on but that's
another story and so what happens is
that they
get this and and and there so to speak
off to the races I would just say very
quickly within the tribe of course what
happens is that they get more money than
God you have a couple hundred people and
now what's happening is that the numbers
are going increasing and you ask
yourself well now where all these
pequots coming from because these are
not babies these are grown people people
in their 40s 50s you know suddenly
they're become pequots well essentially
what happens is that when the Hayward's
started the tribe they basically kept it
pretty tightly controlled and however
they had a problem as Tareen explained
to me said skip a word had a problem
which was he had a reservation but he
didn't have any indians so they needed
more indians i have to tell you this is
the story that you know as you go the
deeper into the story and you know and
the whole thing was i spent my whole
time talking with the Pequots and with
their people and their lawyers and their
documents is just you know my ears
sometimes in the interviews I'm just
stunned at what they were telling me
basically tureen you know says you got
to get some people together you got to
have some people so that they have a
hard time at first getting people before
gambling no one really wants to come to
this little hardscrabble nowhere place
called you know led your Connecticut to
live on a on a rock pile there are no
jobs and nothing there's some federal
handout programs HUD builds some houses
your tax dollars at work which is really
pretty funny I have a whole chapter on
the HUD building of houses for the
Pequots it's a hoot and basically what
happens is that however after Foxwoods
and the money comes rolling in a lot of
people who just as Pequot is the
Hayward's which is to say you know
pretty distantly related to the original
Pequots
the he words I would say skip Hayward is
probably you know maybe 1/32 Pequod I
would say you know I think Eliza was at
most one-eighth his grandmother you know
so your typical Pequod today is
somewhere between 164 and one 128th is
that red one I think that's right
this is getting dangerously close to
zero and and so what happens is when the
money comes in there are other people
who have just as tight a connection to
the historical Pequots as the Hayward's
all you have to do is be able to trace
ancestry to someone who is a resident of
this reservation as of either 1900 or
1910 so you know you have two different
census lists they don't overlap there
are very different people on these two
things I mean these are very transient
places in the late 19th early 20th
century basically anyone who wanted to
live there could sort of just go live
there until the state kicked them out
and that's sort of how it was and if you
look at the state records as I say
they're still confidential which I mean
as a reporter I certainly didn't fry any
documents but I was able to obtain the
documents I needed to obtain I don't
think I ever would have gotten anything
if I'd put a Freedom of Information Act
request in but any event there they're
very clear that the state had no idea
who whether or not these people are not
Indians and frankly wasn't cared and
didn't have the money to find out in any
event the money comes rolling in and
suddenly these other people show up and
they say to the Hayward's I'm Pequot to
and you know what they are to the extent
to which to the PA words are they're
Pequod there's a problem here though
from the Hayward point of view these
people unlike the Hayward's
are all black Hayward's or white I mean
the Hayward's are essentially what I
think most people in southern New
England would know swamp Yankee you know
Hayward's father actually he traces his
ancestry back to the Mayflower so in any
event these black people show up and the
Hayward's are not happy about this eliza
done our best to keep those people away
so now here they show up and there's all
this money well you know you can imagine
what happens you've got all the money in
the world you have a group of people who
have nothing in common except all the
money in the world living on this place
for the first time in generations
ostensibly as a tribe legally certainly
as legally as a tribe but essentially as
one tribal member said to me you know
we're the fur
tried to come together with the central
value of money well now you know this is
not a recipe for happiness and community
it just isn't and much of the story that
that ensues is really the struggle
between these the Hayward family versus
the dark-skinned guys primarily the
sebastian family most of the Sebastien's
actually transferred in from Rhode
Island and from the Narragansett tribal
rolls none of these people by the way
really I mean know that today's peak was
really spent much time in Connecticut
mainly there from Rhode Island New York
California wherever but they're not
really so much from Connecticut and
that's a real actually enormous problem
one of the underlying themes of the book
is that you can have all the money in
the world but you still can't
necessarily a tribe because the tribe is
not really ultimately about money tribe
is all talking about shared values and
traditions and culture and knowing each
other and having having that shared
living history together and the
Mashantucket Pequot Tribal Nation is
there now known just doesn't have any of
that and this is an ongoing struggle for
them meanwhile of course they have their
lives have been enormous ly enriched and
you know all the dollars and they've
gotten people have no idea how much
money they've gotten really a ton of
money and when you look at at the
confidential documents these are people
who are getting you know hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
people who are basically just showing up
really coming from either unemployment
or you know working-class or welfare and
suddenly you know you'd have a kid show
up a high school dropout 19 20 he shows
up he says where's my money I want my
money
literally and so skip Hayward who was
then tribal chairman say well okay we'll
get him some money and these kids were
getting a hundred fifty thousand a year
well you know you can imagine what kind
of social pathologies that can engender
when you have that kind of a group this
is this is the current
reality of this tribe this is what the
reservation is like there's a whole
section here on life on the reservation
I would just like to end here so we can
you know happy to you know talk about
any aspect of this tale to you I would
just like to say that the Pequots of
Connecticut are really oddly enough
despite the the profound lack of
authenticity of this tribe and despite
the fact that this is one of the great
legal scams I have ever come across as a
journalist this is by far the wildest
most amazing transfer of wealth and
legal status I have ever seen anywhere
most people most scams are illegal you
know the amazing thing about this is
that I don't think they broke any major
felony or or laws that I'm familiar with
it's just a story of unintended
consequences and and bravado and and and
in many ways it's a great con job but
these people today are here as they are
the role models interestingly enough for
all the casino tribes that are now Araya
really rising within the nation we
currently have in excess of 200 in
American Indian tribes that have casinos
they're operating in excess of 300
casinos state like California has dozens
and dozens of these but the interesting
thing is that as new as the Pequots are
as a tribe and as new as they are in as
synthetic as they are culturally as a
tribe they're actually one of the older
of the casino tribes so by looking at
the by looking at the Pequots and how
they got it and what they did and the
impact of money in their lives
I really think ironically enough they
are you know you're looking a little bit
of the future when you look at the
Pequots and I think with that I'm happy
to you know open talk about any aspect
of the story you'd like to or time for
right what was his motivation in all
this was do you have an ideological view
and this resistor kind of
entrepreneurial Laurie Tom tureen I have
a chapter on
him it's called TNT and his another his
initials his middle name is Norton and
he wears a big gold belt buckle says TNT
and block letters that's how I know I
asked him when I interviewed him tom was
primarily I think motivated in the 70s
by ideology he came out of the legal
services group in the 60s really seeking
to use the law to advance the rights of
the underprivileged and the underserved
and he happened to end up in Maine
representing those tribes up there but I
think that was his initial motivation
however there's no question in my mind
but that once these tribes got federal
recognition and particularly in
Connecticut once the tribes received you
know these incredibly lucrative gambling
franchises in the Pequod's case a
monopoly for quite a number of years
until the Mohegan came along and now
they have a duopoly which is still
pretty good any if there's an economist
in the crowd I'm sure they can explain
why that's the case but it's a good
business to be a duopoly at that point
Tom terrine segwayed from the pro bono
lawyer to the for-profit lawyer slash
investment advisor and he I think
realized that you know working for
whatever the you know government hourly
rates were as a lawyer was not really as
exciting as taking a fee on the size of
an investment banking deal and you know
tom is very rich right now and
significantly I think that he has
morphed from the pro bono to the
investment banker he just happens to be
doing it in a knot on Wall Street as a
matter of fact just I would say
parenthetically about Tom Tom is
actually currently the architect of the
Indian casino referendum in Maine he's
trying to bring this to Maine
he tried to do this you know back in the
late 70s but he was stopped by the state
of Maine but tom is a very bold and
persistent and and resourceful lawyer
and you know he doesn't give up yeah my
name is Mack Turner I'm on the board of
selectmen in North Stoney and a lot of
this is familiar and by the way Tom
terrain it was there was an article in
The Boston Globe about the contract that
he has that if a casino does develop in
Maine he stands to make double the money
he's worth today but you closed with a
comment about the future and I when I
finished your book I was sort of
wondering the day just it at the New
London day did a editorial section
commemorating the anniversary 20th
anniversary of the ironically the
settlement Act which hasn't settled much
for us right what do you see in the
future where do you I mean the day's
Arctica toriel's all seem to be trying
to provide us with guidance of what we
should or shouldn't do and what we
should expect in the future I wonder
where you see this all headed okay let
me I'll talk just first about
Connecticut and then sort of nationally
in Connecticut Connecticut faces a very
difficult situation the the horse is so
well out of the barn that there is
always a tendency to say well listen
let's just try to deal with it and that
just basically means dealing with the
status quo I think that my my my view
and and as I said you know I live in
Connecticut I'm voter and taxpayer
myself although not in the part of the
state where this is story takes place I
think that the problem that Connecticut
faces is that it's never ever had any
coherent or coordinated policy Hartford
has never been interested I mean you
were nor Stonington all know this as
well as anyone that the Hartford
basically ignored you guys for years and
if it could it would still ignore you so
that's it's the political reality
however what's happening now is
there's an increasing proliferation and
it may be that this won't simply be a
problem for Eastern Connecticut it may
move to Fairfield County Litchfield
County and elsewhere this is obviously
getting there for people upset I think
that what's going to happen is that I
think Connecticut really should
establish almost its own over it needs a
well-funded group and it can't have to
be permanent can't be a temporary thing
that is going to have to deal with these
tribes and if it needs to take the
tribes on whether it's on questions of
recognition or whether it's on
regulation or environmental issues or
zoning issues or what-have-you the state
of Connecticut is really going to have
to represent the interests of the people
of Connecticut more I think in the Maine
what's happened in recent you know since
1993 when they got slots is that the
state Hartford is just happy to get the
money from the slots kickback and that's
all they care about and it's really the
bean counters at the division of special
revenue who are the only people who
focus on it on a consistent basis and
they really only care to the extent to
which the money comes in so you know
what should what should Connecticut do
about it I don't think that they can
it's going to be very hard to get rid of
the Pequots of the Mohegan just
practically and the only way to do that
would be to go to Washington and that
would be a fight that I don't get the
sense there's much appetite for now so I
think they're gonna have to make their
peace but they're a whole as you know
many other tribes or groups who want to
be tribes and want that recognition in
line and in Connecticut you know federal
recognition is tantamount or is presumed
to be tantamount to give me a casino
that means that this small state could
potentially within several years have
another three to four casinos that's not
in any way out of the realm of
possibility at all personally I don't
see gambling as the economic driver that
made Connecticut the richest state in
the Union we're talking significantly
about lower skilled lower wage jobs so I
don't feel as
that that's a great way to develop it I
also think there are obviously major
social costs that the state as far as I
can tell has absolutely no interest in
addressing I find that somewhat amusing
contradictory given how aggressive we've
been for example on the ills of
cigarettes it's just surprising to me
that here in Connecticut no one has the
slightest interest in any of the
Associated side-effects of gambling
which are very problematic and anyone
who lives in Connecticut and knows no
stories of people who have just really
gone to wrack and ruin on this
nationally nationally I just think that
you know Connecticut in this weird way
is really sort of the epicenter of this
sort of Indian gambling thing and so I
think that the rest of the country
whether they know it or not are quite
likely to run into many of these same
problems they'll just be five or ten or
twenty years later
Connecticut is early to the party and
therefore some of the problems are
showing up earlier here but I think that
the rest of the country is going to face
that and I think if that happens there
will be increased struggles on Capitol
Hill I think states are going to be
going and they're going to be revisiting
some of the issues related to the
federal Indian tribes limited
sovereignty the relationship between the
tribe and the federal government the
relationship between the federal
government and States and I think this
will be tested in court I think it will
be tested in in in in elections we saw
this most recently in California in the
recall referendum lieutenant governor
Bustamante was basically financed almost
solely by the recently by the California
casino tribes that's basically who
funded his entire campaign and when this
came up there was quite a backlash that
took place in California and a number of
analysts including I saw some articles
in my old paper The Washington Post
attributed his demise at the polls to
people not liking this
and I think that that's going to happen
more and more I think that this whole
issue of Indian casinos is just gonna
it's it's it has not peaked as a
political issue
would you get a comment just an aside on
the Mohegans parallel the Pequots in
there same thing are they more Indian
I'd be happy to talk about the Mohican I
didn't study them anywhere near as
closely but let me give you my thoughts
because they make an interesting
contrast in certain ways with pequots
the Mohegan had no reservation up until
very recently they didn't actually have
a reservation but what they did have in
Montville was they had a small community
of people which is interesting you see
the Pequod's had a reservation and no
tribe the Mohegans had no reservation
but they had some tribal life and
primarily was gladys tantaquidgeon her
brother and some of the people who were
closed to them they maintained a church
and they did maintain some ongoing
cultural tribal life and tradition and
so you know i would say that from that
point of view that's a difference they
are from connecticut these people have
lived in connecticut there's no question
that they've been part and parcel of the
history these are not johnny-come-lately
to some kind of Indian identity another
thing that's interesting about the
Mohegan I think is that they have a
little Museum I don't know if anyone has
seen the museum but it it's it's I
remember being taken there by one of the
Mohegan tribal members it is you know a
couple of rooms might be beats 5000
square feet I'm not sure but it's tiny
but it actually has Mohegan artifacts
it's amazing
in contrast and I have a chapter on this
in the book the peak was just built a
250 million dollar Pequot museum this is
now this is this was the biggest museum
project going in the United States at
the time it was the only thing they've
been bigger than it was the Getty that
was the last big project and then there
was this and they had you know James
Stewart pole shack who is a very well
known esteemed New York architect he
recently did the new planetarium in New
York City at the Natural History Museum
do their Museum they had the exhibit
designers who had done the Nixon Library
come in from California to do all the
exhibits you know this is a crackerjack
crew of professionals the only problem
with the peak
what museum is not that it's not
beautiful Museum and that it's very
elegantly done without question but
there are no Pequot artifacts really in
it and that is sort of problematic and
there's an entire chapter because I
spend a lot of time with the people who
put this museum together and I wanted to
hear the story and that's what I learned
from them is that basically this Pequot
museum is not a museum of Pequod history
or artifacts this is Museum of basically
northeastern woodland Indians and a lot
of the exhibits I thought it's sort of
somewhat amusing because as a child I
remember that you know in Connecticut
you would be taken to you know we used
to be taken to the Wonder Bread Factory
and we'd be taken to the Science Museum
and I think Bridgeport or what-have-you
and you know kids school kids go to this
museum and I I don't know what their
teachers think about what these kids are
seeing but I'll tell you one thing it is
not a Pequot museum and I would say
that's a contrast with the Mohegan and
it's very sim sim to mattock and
symbolic of one group basically the
Pequots were in a very tough situation
after Foxwoods from a public relations
point of view and therefore from a
political point of view potentially they
had status they had riches but they
didn't have any culture that's a problem
when the rest of the people in America
are thinking that the reason you're
getting the casino is because you are an
Indian tribe so therefore you need to
begin to do some things that are more
tribal the museum was part and parcel of
that another thing was the invention
that took they invented a powwow in
about 1990 I have a the chapter on the
invention of the powwow they call its
commits in' Terry Bell remember she was
the one she's the granddaughter who got
married in the miniskirt and skip had
the big Western headdress on this is the
same Terry Bell she's she went to her
big brother skip and she said you know
skipper you know I've we've always
wanted a powwow could we have a powwow
and now they have the money they had the
money at that point have a powwow and so
what happened was they
and they looked in the history books and
you know they've hired this tribe is
employed you know more anthropologists
archaeologists and historians and you
can shake a stick at let me tell you and
they get they get together and they come
up with scheme it'san and one of the
things that prompted it was that they
were getting into these embarrassing
situations for example they were flying
over one time to see the financed ears
of Foxwoods now these are the offshore
Chinese they live in Malaysia they run
the biggest gambling Emporium in in Asia
well they are the ones who financed the
initial did the initial financing for
the Pequod's so the Pequots in the early
90s a group of them are going over to
you know to see their business partners
they stopped over in Hawaii in Hawaii
there's a Polynesian Cultural Center and
as a courtesy they typically offer
visiting aboriginal groups the
opportunity to share their culture their
living culture
so these pequots you know they just like
they just go they're not certain what's
going to happen and they are asked to in
some manner sing one of their tribal
songs this story was told to me by
tribal members who were there who
participated in this and so there they
are and they have to share their culture
and they all go what are we going to do
what song do we all know and so they
sang you are my sunshine you know this
is the kind of an interview where you
know as a reporter which is what I am
I'm very empirical that's what reporters
are you try to you work hard to get
access you try to get people who are
reliable to tell you everything you can
get them to tell you and then you follow
the story wherever that leads and you
know when I heard this you know I mean I
had many many interviews like this where
you know I had gone II I've gone into
the story with hey I was a Washington
Post reporter you can imagine you know
I'm not the deeply conservative
ideologue you know and even I would go
and and you know my eyes sort of pop
open a little bit at that
so that's the problem they have
culturally I don't think the Mohegan
have that problem what the Mohegan
ancestry is in the blood-quantum and all
that I haven't looked into that I don't
know I do know that anyone from the
state who lives near there can say that
the Mohegan appear to be better
neighbors
I think that's primarily cultural when I
say cultural I don't mean Indian culture
I mean just a Connecticut the culture of
Connecticut small towns you know if you
know someone and you know how people
deal with each other you tend to have
things go a little more harmoniously and
I think the Mohegan had had a little bit
they've maybe they learn from the
Pequots maybe it's because they're from
Connecticut but I think they've had a
slightly less tortured political
existence I would agree with you but I
tell people when they say why do the
Mohegans have such a better relationship
than the Mashantucket s-- with the
surrounding towns
they've never filed an annexation
lawsuit we just after a year and a half
of courtroom battles won a tax appeal
where the Mashantucket said that we were
over taxing them for the land on
twenty-five parcels of land and the
courts referred to the case as frivolous
and we won all 25 cases the Mohegans
give $500,000 an impact aid from the
very beginning of their casino to the
town of Montville we don't get a dime
from the nation' targets so it's it's
not cultural in in in a simplest sense
or in the sense that it can be distorted
to refer to us as racist it is there
there are real political nuts and bolts
about the relationship we have with
Mohegans and the relationship with the
Mashantucket so that are very different
i die i agree with that i guess what i
meant by cultural is that i think that
that the fact that I think we basically
agree I think the fact that the Mohegan
behave in that manner to me bespeaks
people who have some understanding of
where they are and what they're doing I
think the Pequots basically literally
were the men from Mars
who just landed in the middle of the
countryside of Connecticut and hadn't a
clue about many many things and one of
the things was how do you deal with with
all the people who have been there
longer than you have been I mean this is
a story filled with rich with ironies
but many of the people who are in the
surrounding towns of the Pequots their
families have been there a whole lot
longer than a lot of these Pequots
there's no question about that
yeah in terms of Indian Gaming in
various parts of the country you seem to
indicate that most of it is on in tribes
of sort of shaky definition no no I
don't mean to suggest that I mean to
suggest really that no no I don't I
don't mean suggest that what I mean to
suggest is that the the gambling is now
seen as the panacea for tribes and to
some extent for these states that seek
to profit or get a kickback essentially
from the tribes and that's what I meant
so that the the I think that the problem
actually for other Indian tribes and
many many Indians have said this to me
in the course of reporting the book is
that you know they don't like their the
this is the Pequots are in many ways
symptomatic of I think the future for a
lot of tribes because money can
overwhelm tribes very easily
particularly large pots of money but no
I wouldn't say that I'm not going to
question the authenticity of American
Indian tribes I actually find what's
more outrageous is the fact that the
Pequots and I'm sure the Pequots are not
alone I'm sure there are a few others
that are somewhat self-invented you know
these guys to become so rich and we got
other Indian tribes that are actually
real tribes that are poor and they're
not getting a dime I was going to ask
you of the very large tribes the ones
that seem to hell in big tracts of dry
land and then in the West or any of them
getting rich well you know I mean I'm
not sayin if you take a look at the Hopi
the Navajo
some of the best known etc there's one
scene in the book where this was told to
me by an American Indian who worked for
the Pequots in Washington for a long
time
skip Hayward would go down to Washington
and sort of not necessarily even
intentionally just sort of lord over all
these other Indian leaders at these
Indian meetings in Washington how much
money he was making and you know is this
is this fellow said to me said you know
you can imagine how the head of the
Navajo feels he's overseeing a
population of you know thousands and
thousands of people and he might get
paid maybe $50,000 a year and he's
basically administering you know a very
complex set of grant monies in a very
limited budget and this guy said to me
how do you think these other tribes feel
about the Pequots you know they're not
thrilled and so I would say that that's
probably the case and I would also say
that I in defense in a way of the
Pequots um you know Americans have a
pretty ignorant about a lot of the
realities I think about American Indian
life and I haven't certainly made a deep
exploration of every tribe and I think
that that's that's for others to do it's
not that's not for me to do I want to
say one thing parenthetically about the
government of the Pequod's because I was
thinking about this apropos the Navajo
one of the I thought one of the great
most amusing statistics that I
discovered in the book is the size of
the Pequod's government which is I would
you know if you look at their
confidential documents you see how many
people they employ and there was a time
when they had in excess of 1,200
employees for the tribal government at a
time when the tribal population was
roughly 500 I thought that was
impressive you know I thought that was
great you know you could have a tribal
government two to three times the size
of the population now that is having a
lot of money to burn um yeah
Pequots initially getting the
reservation started or their casino
started you mentioned that there were
some American entrepreneurs who
expressed interest and then just
recently you mentioned that there were
Chinese entrepreneurs can you give a
little more fleshing out of the the role
of the international investors and
whether that relationship still exists
today and what it might entail sure I'd
be I'd be happy to when the Pequod's
were looking for financing back you know
first for for bingo
in 86 or 85 86 but then particularly for
Foxwoods in the period between 90 and 92
gambling didn't look like a slam-dunk to
the bankers of Connecticut anyone who's
ever known any of the bankers of
Connecticut historically you know
parenthetically for all those who are
insid in banking history in the great
sort of economic slump of the early 90s
just about every single Connecticut bank
went bust so you know it's sort of they
weren't this we're not the swiftest
bankers in the world they were not going
to lend money for this crazy idea to
have a casino in Connecticut they
thought that was you know for the birds
you know what's that that's nutty you
know if you want to do something they
understood they didn't understand this
so therefore the attorneys for the
Pequots and these were really guys two
lawyers who had work with Tom tureen and
we're still working with Tareen at that
point very talented very brilliant
lawyers guy named Barry Margolin and a
guy named Rob Kipps two of the brightest
very liberal guys come out of Harvard
Barry was one of the leaders of SDS in
Harvard in the late 60s
brilliant brilliant theoretician legal
theoretician great litigator great
negotiator and just brainy and you know
Barry and Rob that's on the book you
know they they were pretty sure
themselves about well this isn't a
problem you know we'll just be fighting
off the finance ears you know they're
going to see what a beautiful
opportunity this is they're going to see
our vision well they sort of found out
that no no one really saw their vision
so they started scraping the bottom of
the barrel and that led them to you know
a variety of different people there was
some mafia guys who approached at one
point they got sort of pushed away thank
God but then they ended up with
basically this offshore Chinese family
and the other guys were the do they
remember Bert Lance from the from the
remember Bert Lance and and remember the
bank he was involved the arab-american
bank well those guys wanted to lend
money to I mean so you had yeah he went
to jail for that yes that's exactly
right
well I mean it was those guys and the
Malaysians really end up as the
finalists and then you know and then you
had you had I think you had a Japanese
bank that wanted to get in but they were
a little bit too too nosy I think that
the Pequod's wanted real autonomy the
gist of it is that basically US banks at
that point thought that there was legal
political risk Connecticut might shut
them down and then what would you do you
lent money to these guys they're on a
federal Indian Reservation what's that
about that's akin to having a legal
status of an army base how are you gonna
get your money and and let's assume you
built them a casino and they don't pay
or it doesn't work out what are you
gonna do take the casino back I mean
you're in the middle of nowhere what if
they say yeah here I have my casino but
the state won't let you have any slot
machines or any gambling in it you have
the biggest warehouse in the middle of
the woods so you know people working to
do that so basically what happened was
finally they went they cut a deal with
the Chinese these offshore Chinese from
Malaysia who run the biggest you know
gambling casino in Asia and these guys
in the the confidential documents show
that basically they get nine point nine
percent of the gross for I think 25
years it's in the book so they're 20 or
25 years they also get a foreigner I
think it's a four to four and a half
point spread over a floating 10-year
interest rate arm and that's their cut
which and then the state of Connecticut
basically gets as I said 25 percent of
the slots kick
the wind that goes to the state
essentially the Pequots are able to keep
75% of the net income um if you look at
the Pequot confidential documents on the
profitability of Foxwoods fox revenues
are roughly or 1.2 billion now some of
that is hotel but primarily the profits
is is the gambling and primarily the
slots you're talking about an enterprise
that's generating somewhere in the range
of 200 million it will vary from year to
year and of course this is not really
taxed at the federal level because it is
a federally recognized tribes are not
taxed they are treated like a
municipality or a state and of course
the state gets the slots kickback but
their note other taxes that take place
on the reservation and the town's
needless to say are at the bottom of
this particular ladder and they don't
have any taxing authority either so name
it with regard to the financing the the
Chinese one out there's been falling out
there's no question there's been falling
out between the two of them but you know
what the chinese serve very good
business people and they're getting paid
and if they ever have a dispute it's
stipulated right in the documents that
any legal dispute between them and the
Pequots will be adjudicated in federal
court you know the Pequod's have a
tribal court if you go to the if you go
to the if you go to you know if you slip
on you know trip over some slot machine
or something i don't know you know or
you take a header in the parking lot
though you'll you'll be in tribal court
you that's that's the legal status i
hope does that does that answer your
question a little bit great sure yeah so
the deal that Weicker made with the
tribe had to do with the kickback on the
selassie yeah that's the that was well
that was he he comes into the story in
three elements one he was one of the the
proponents for the the land claim
settlement legislation in 83 he
then comes in as the newly elected
governor and he's attempts to actually
stop Foxwoods from getting going he
loses in the state legislature and then
the next year having lost that and the
casinos up and running all that he then
is confirmed with possibility slots and
at that point he is attempting to keep
steve wynn and those guys out of the
state the you know deep irony is that
Lowell Weicker felt that he was he was
really by doing giving them slots
he was really stopping the spread of
gambling in the state of Connecticut
well I don't think so because Foxwoods
is the biggest casino in the world
Mohegan Sun is now I believe the second
biggest and you've got three at least
three other groups in the state seeking
federal recognition and therefore
casinos I think that this thing
essentially I believe that Indian
gambling in Connecticut right now is
essentially completely out of the
control of the state and it's very out
of control right here and I think that's
one of the things that is actually
causing anxiety increasingly in Hartford
and in parts of the state other than
just Eastern Connecticut so so one more
question I just got the word sure hey
we're doing today ah
that's sort of a sad story actually skip
who is a really very charming fellow was
deposed by the beta by the blacks he was
deposed to tribal chairman in 1998
essentially the it was sheer Democrat
demographics not really anything more
than that he had held on probably longer
than would demographics might have
suggested he had a certain charisma and
after all he had founded the tribe you
know and a lot of these other people
really were only rich courtesy of him
and his family and there was a little
residual you know that that that
attended attended to that he is he was
defeated he's still on the Tribal
Council doesn't come to tribal meetings
I think he's you can
imagine how he feels you know here he
got this whole thing started and now the
reservation is run by all these people
that his family tried to keep out all
those years and I know that his his
brothers and sisters and very some of
his relations have remonstrated him for
letting those people in to begin with
and you know he's a little bit like the
head of a giant company the founder of
the company as it were who then gets
overthrown in a boardroom coup and it's
just kept on as window dressing it's a
it's a powerless and in some way
humiliating thing so he's rich no
question he's rich and he has a house
along the shore he still has a house on
the reservation but the tribal members
who live on his road that I interviewed
never ever see him there just uses it
for receptions and parties and
fundraisers and excuse me yeah and the
other the question was raised implicitly
about the tax right often this is a
whole thing that you know this is for
the state of Connecticut's revenue
department to deal with which is do
these tribal members actually live on
the reservation or not there's no
question in my mind but my interviews
with tribal members who are well
familiar with particularly skips
domestic situation in years past I'm not
talking about the current moment but
when I was doing my reporting there's no
question but that they never saw him on
the reservation he didn't want to be on
the reservation he was he'd had it up to
here with these people you know he was
tired of everyone showing up and saying
where's my money where's my money give
me the money and I think he's not a man
who likes dealing with that and he has
his own personal challenges and I think
that I can well understand why he wanted
to you know bugger off and what whether
it not he's been paying taxes to the
state and the towns that really is
between him and his accountant and the
tax authorities
so listen thanks so much appreciate your
all coming thanks for all the great
question
Bret Bronson writes daily for the street
comm hitting the jackpot is published by
Atlantic Monthly press on the web at
Atlantic Monthly dot-com we take you to
a panel on the historical